Welcome back everyone is Charlie
HBO just revealed that it's
casting the new Game of Thrones
Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
prequel series.
George R.R. Martin's also revealed
a bunch of details about it.
So we'll break it all down.
It's also going into production way faster
than we thought that it would,
so we actually might see episodes
pretty soon.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course
I'll do videos for all the episodes,
just like I do for House of the Dragon,
like I did for Game of Thrones.
Any of the other prequel series
or sequel series that they wind up
releasing the next couple of years?
there's a lot of them.
I'll talk about some of the other ones
at the end of the video.
How's the Dragon's season?
Two episodes
should release during next summer.
They're still on track for that,
even though there have been
a couple of strikes.
Don't worry about that.
I've already done a couple of videos
about all the footage,
the teasers they've released,
so I'll put links to that down
in the description below.
And at the end of this but starting
with the big stuff, Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms is based on the tales of dunk
and egg stories that George R.R.
Martin wrote.
There are three novellas, basically,
and they were just collected in a larger
book called A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms,
which is where the series gets
its name from,
they might tweak the name
just a little bit to keep from getting
super long because the full title
now has a subtitle called The Hedge Knight.
That might just be for season one
because the three Duncan Egg novellas
are called A Hedge Knight, which is a
reference to Ser Duncan the Tall.
Book two is called The Sworn Sword,
which is also a reference to Ser Duncan,
the swearing his sword to Aegon
the fifth in the last novella book
three is called The Mystery Knight,
which as you could have guessed
it, big surprise is also a reference
to Ser Duncan the Tall.
within the world of a song of Ice
and Fire in Westeros.
A mystery Knight is someone who competes
in a tournament like a joust
without revealing their identity
or using a pseudonym or a fake name
during the tales of Duncan Egg dunk fights
in a tournament celebrating the wedding
of Ser Ambrose Butterworth
using a pseudonym
called The Gallows Knight
instead of his real name.
probably the most famous example of
another mystery Knight in Game of Thrones
history was Lyanna Stark, who fought
in the Great Tourney of Herron Hall
during the tournament, a younger Howland
Reed, seen here later in the timeline
with a young Ned Stark,
was bullied by three squires
of other knights at the tournament.
Lyanna Stark came to his aid,
beat off the attackers with the sword
like while she was dressed as Lyanna
Certainly she had her dress on,
then later entered the tournament
disguised as the Knight of the Laughing
Tree with armor that had a tree on it
that appeared to be laughing.
It drove the Mad King even more mad
because he thought the tree
was actually laughing at him.
because you remember by this point
he's grown incredibly insane in supposedly
the great tourney of Herron
Hall was a ruse
that Rhaegar Targaryen threw in order
to try and call a great tournament
and get the rest of the round
to support him deposing his father
and him taking the iron throne.
there are a lot of theories
about that during
the original Game of Thrones novels,
but they never definitively answered
if that's what regards original plan was.
Maybe we'll hear about that in some future
Robert's Rebellion series at some point.
but. During that great tournament
when Lyanna Stark was pretending
to be the Knight of the laughing tree,
he defeated the three knights
that those squires were serving
in the three defeated knights
agreed to severely chastise their squires
as a way for Lyanna to help
get some justice for Howland Reed
Because he'd been afraid
to actually challenge
the squires in open combat like you
normally would in a situation like that,
but the news you may have seen
your feeds recently is that HBO
is now casting the roles of Sir Duncan,
the Tall and Prince Aegon
the fifth for a planned
filming date during 2024.
At least that's what
the casting announcement looks like.
They're going to be filming next year,
which is way faster than I think
we expected I'm still not expecting them
to release episodes to like 2026.
But if they aren't able to get House
of the Dragon season three out by 2025,
we might actually get lucky.
And they just released Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms
between seasons of House of the Dragon
A while ago, George R.R.
Martin made it sound like season
one of Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
would only have about six episodes.
So be on the shorter side.
But supposedly
the episode count could wind up changing.
HBO wasn't really happy
when the original series
started doing those shorter seasons,
and they're not really happy.
The House of the Dragon Season
two had to reduce their episode count to
but house the dragon's
actually a good template for what
Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms is going to be like.
So when House the Dragons started
a lot of fans were worried
that there wouldn't be enough material
for them to adapt to normal series
because the actual dance of the Dragons
Targaryen Civil War that it's covering
only lasted for a couple of years.
Like it was actually pretty quick.
George R.R.
Martin only wrote a couple of short
stories
covering that in the Fire and Blood book
that he wrote is more of an appendices
like a Silmarillion type
of book written by a master who narrates
when certain things happen in history.
It's not written like an actual novel,
like the main song of Ice and Fire novels
that they adapted for the main series.
like when they did the original series,
they had really big novels to adapt
for most of the seasons.
Obviously, when the show started to go off
the rails is when they lost
all the material to adapt verse,
everyone's worries
when they get to the House of the Dragon.
And some of these are the prequels,
but they don't have
a ton of material to adapt.
but if George R.R.
Martin is writing,
he wrote on House of the Dragon.
He's writing on Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms, helping them expand the story.
And if it weren't fine
for House of the Dragon,
it'll probably work fine
for any of the other periods in history
they want to cover.
Well, funny you should ask.
Let me get my map.
so as long as he's the one that's
actually expanding the material
for those different time
periods, I'm not worried about the story.
Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms would pick up about 80 years
after the first black bi rebellion.
So the other cool thing about the series,
they can feature the Blood Raven, Brendan
Rivers, a.k.a. the Three-Eyed Raven.
Before he became the Three-Eyed Raven
he was very active
during this period in history.
He was a Targaryen bastard of Aegon,
the fourth.
He was the infamous king
who started so many bastards
that it put Robert at the end of shame.
He hated his legitimate oldest son
who was heir to the iron throne,
legitimized a bunch of the bastards
creating house black fire, which directly
leads to the Black Fire rebellion.
It causes a whole bunch of problems.
the survivors of that wound up going off
to Essos to create the Golden Company.
Brendan Rivers fought on the side
of his half brother, King Darren.
The second obviously was half brothers
with all the black fighters too.
so this is another Targaryen Civil war
like the House of the Dragon
Dance of the Dragons.
It was just a bunch of bastards
versus a bunch of true born people.
Brendan Rivers supported the true born
side, the actual crown basically
the reason why he was called the Blood
Raven though, was because of a birthmark
covering most of his face
in after his half brother King Darren.
The second died from an illness.
After the Blackfire rebellion,
He became the hand of the king
and the master of whispers to Darren's son
Brynden's nephew, Aerys,
the first after he took the Iron throne.
Then Aerys dies without an heir.
So the iron throne passes to his brother
Maekar the first.
And it's around that period
the Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
series would be taking place.
The story begins when Heir is the first
is still sitting on the Iron throne.
But after the Blackfire rebellion
and before Aegon, the fifth father
maker, the first succeeds
his brother Aerys is the next king.
would they might do on the show though, is
because most of this takes place
when Aegon the fifth is squire to Sir
Duncan the tall like when he's
much younger and is having adventures
going around the different seven kingdoms
but because Aegon the fifth eventually
does become the next king in Ser Duncan.
The taller becomes the Lord Commander
of his kingsguard eventually they'll probably have
Some flash forward
to where he actually becomes
the next king in the name Sir Duncan.
The title to the Kingsguard this is, where
the title of the Collected Books
gets its name.
Because when you become a Kingsguard,
you become a Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
a like the whole trajectory of the series,
it's like the rise of Sir Duncan,
the title in The Rise of Aegon the fifth.
but because so much of the series
takes place when they're much younger.
I think that's
what most of the episodes will be in in
those be like a quick flash forward
at the end of the series to him actually
becoming king in Sir
Duncan the Tall becoming a Kingsguard.
they're probably not going to do
the tragedy of summerhall
because that happened
way later in Aegon that this life
and because Aegon
the fifth was the younger brother of Mr.
Aemon on the show Game of Thrones.
We might actually see
a much younger version of Mr.
Aemon
the whole idea is that Aegon
the fifth became the next king of Westeros
as part of a great council
where they were selecting the next king.
but when that was happening, Mr.
Aemon was actually ahead of him
in the line of succession,
so part of the idea is that Mr.
Aymond
didn't want to cause another Targaryen
Civil War battle over succession
so soon after the Blackfire rebellion,
and he didn't want to leave the master,
so he chose to take the black instead,
basically leading the great council
to select Aegon.
The fifth is like the next
likely successor.
There was a brief moment during the
original Game of Thrones series where Mr.
Aymond is talking to Jon
Snow about his true heritage.
Like I am a Targaryen,
I had to sit through all these different
conflicts, the rise of the Mad King,
everything that happened
with the neighbors,
you know, I wasn't able to help them
even though I wanted to like mainstream
and actually wanted to leave
and help the nearest
when everything happened with the Mad King
and Robert's rebellion.
so it was much earlier in the timeline.
He still like a lot of characters
who were alive during the main series
Game of Thrones.
Also, Melisandre
is like one of the oldest characters
in the main series and game of Thrones.
She could show up at any point
during this part of the timeline.
the other interesting thing too,
is about the Bloodraven black stories.
So when Mr.
Amos took the black and went to the wall,
the blood raven also took the black
and went to the wall,
He even rose to the rank of Lord
Commander of the night's watch
before he became the Three-Eyed Raven.
But the reason why the blood raven took
the black
was because of a separate event
involving the death
of one of the black fighters
during the great tournament.
It was like one of Aegon,
the first first acts to actually
have him arrested
and gave him the choice to take the black.
So let's take a whole different video
about the history of the blood raven as is
you really interesting.
So if we learn more about the character
on the Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
series,
I'll do a much bigger video about him.
but when the Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
series picks up, he's basically
hand of the king.
So it makes sense that we would
actually see him during the series.
Let me know in the comments.
So who do you want to play? Duncan Egg?
I would totally be fine
if they were unknown actors
that we don't know anything about.
I don't mind their
not being a super famous actors
on any of the Game of Thrones series,
even though there are a couple
on House of the Dragon,
they probably won't announce more
the actual characters, the casting
until next year,
but they can probably do
like a solid three
or four seasons out of this, just like
they're doing for House of the Dragon.
Like I said, expanding the story
with George R.R.
Martin being the one
to actually expand the story.
what they'll probably do, though,
is that once House of the Dragon Season
four airs this Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
series would take over,
become like the main series.
And then they do like the next sequel
series, spin off and so on and so forth.
there's still a bunch of others
that they're working on, like the Jon Snow
sequel series, The Sea Snake Series,
about his nine voyages,
like the nine famous voyages
and conquests around the world.
A Princess Nymeria the 10,000 Ship series
about the history of Dorne.
there's an animated series
that they're working on.
There's the Aegon's Conquest series,
which might just be like a future House
of the Dragon series.
The idea is that they'll do more
Targaryen periods in history
and just still call it House the Dragon,
but cover different periods in history.
sort of be like House of the Dragon
Subtitle Conquest for Aegon's Conquest.
the only series that I've heard about them
actually canceling is the flea bottom
series. I'm totally fine
and then not doing that.
But there's a bunch of others
that we'll probably hear
about in like the next several years.
Like they'll still do Game of Thrones
sequel series,
spinoff series
till the Heat Death of the Universe.
So I'm going to be like 90 years old
someday
doing breakdowns for a new Game of Thrones
episodes.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Everyone click here for All My House,
The Dragon, Season two Teasers.
And first Look videos.
Learn about what's going on
with all the characters
and click here to learn about that
Game of Thrones Jon Snow Sequel Series.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!